احتقان جديد في الاقصى بعد اقتحامات
للمستوطنين
طفل يسرق سياره ويتسبب بكارثه في
كاليفورنيا
دراسه تربط بين موسم الصيف وزياده
الاحتيال الرقمي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
في احتقان جديد في المسجد الاقصى اقتحم
اكثر من 1500 مستوطن اسرائيلي باحات
المسجد بعد دخولهم من جهه باب المغاربه
وتحت حراسه الشرطه الاسرائيليه قام
المستوطنون بجولات استفزازيه بقياده عضو
الكنيسه السابق موشيفلان فيما وصلت الشرطه
فرض اجراءات مشدده وتقييدات على دخول
الفلسطينيين للمسجد وتزامن مع ذلك وقوع
مواجهه بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
على جبل صبيح جنوب نابلس خلفت نحو 120
اصابه
حادثه ماساويه وغريبه تسبب بها طفل في
الولايات المتحده شرطه كاليفورنيا اعلنت
في بيان ان سياره كان يقودها الطفل اصطدمت
بسيارتين اثناء مطارده الشرطه لها ما ادى
الى مقتل امراه واصابه 12 شخصا البيان
اضاف ان الطفل يبلغ من العمر 13 عاما وان
السياره كانت مسروقه فيما اكدت شرطه
كاليفورنيا انه تم نقل الطفل الى المستشفى
بعد اصابته وانه سيتم احتجازه في سجن
الاحداث بمجرد انتهاء العلاج الطبيه
في عالم العملات الرقميه تعالت اصوات
التحذير من احتمال زياده عمليات الاحتيال
خلال فصل الصيف دراسه اجرتها منصه
كشفت ان ملايين الدولارات تختفي كل يوم
بسبب الجرائم الرقميه التي ترتبط بالعملات
المشفره مؤكده ان نسبه عمليات الاحتيال قد
ترتفع خلال شهر يونيو الذي يطلق عليه شهر
الاحتيال الرقمي كون معظم عمليات السحب
تتم في فتره العطلات الموسميه الامر الذي
يستغله المحتلون
في انجاز تكنولوجيه وصف بالمبهر طور علماء
الصينيون نوعا من الجلد الالكتروني مصنوع
من الحرير الطبيعي بهدف تمكين الروبوتات
من الحركه والتنقل في الظلام عبر حاسه
اللمس وبحسب وكاله الانباء الصينيه فان
الجلد الالكترونيه يحاكي خصائص جلد
الانسان ويتميز بنعومته وانه يحتوي على
جميع الخصائص الفيزيائيه والكيميائيه
الشبيهه بالجلد مثل قابليته للتمدد وقدرته
على الالتئام الذاتي والحموضه الضعيفه
والانشطه المضاده للبكتيريا كما انه يشعر
بدرجه الحراره والضغط والرطوبه في الظروف
المحيطه به بمجرد تشغيله